you to respond to him yeah what's up
with you you can't text to me you
directly I had to talk emails nine
emails for you to come here
wait Dermer had to contact you to get to
this point contact you don't text me
back that's true also you have green
bubbles I don't wanna text you that's
true so where I really don't want to
text people with green bubbles that's
way way so I should get I have to get an
iPhone everyone the reason why I have a
Samsung is began trying to be Korean
loyal I I get that right I do have no
like ethnic ties to [ __ ] no that's
because I'm just a weird little meat
puppet from Yugoslavia / Los Angeles /
like nothing yeah I've no ties to
anything you're a Viking yeah no I'm not
I wish I'd be way hotter I would have
blonde hair my skin would be glowing you
would see no pores yeah I got pores dude
I got big pores yeah big pores for an
Asian Asians all my skin yeah you also
have like Asians are not supposed to get
liver spots I'm so I know they're
freckles I mean these giant freckles
yeah but generally I think you look
really young though fighting words
you look great sweetie look at me I'm a
male so you say this is what you say you
say this is what you say to your
boyfriend you say umm I have big pores
on my face if you told agents aren't
supposed to get liver spots I mean
freckles big freckles you look great
aside from those two glaring
discrepancies on your face
oh I'm kidding I love you that's what we
do I like this
is that wrong yeah man no she'll be mad
[Music]